after last week's painful top five I
feel like I owe you guys something so
for today's episode I decided to bring
in a real Star Wars expert straight from
his own YouTube channel please welcome
hello Guido hey there Walter thanks for
having me on the show it's an honor to
have you here my friend you ready to get
this countdown started absolutely I've
been waiting for it but I gotta ask
what's up with the power ranger helmet
oh I just wanted to make you feel at
home you don't have to do that for me
man oh it's no problem I'm pretty comfy
in here I appreciate that but but it's
fine you can take it off no no I insist
I have to accommodate my guests really
it's okay you don't have to wear that I
think I did Walter take off the helmet
okay
we're all still processing the last Jedi
so I'm closing out Star Wars months and
2017 with the best of the best
along with hello Greedo these are the
top five best Star Wars original trilogy
moments number five
[Music]
this is my personal favorite scene and
all of Star Wars the symbolism the score
the environment this scene has
everything I love about Star Wars packed
right into it
Luke Skywalker and unsure young man torn
with what he wants to do with his life
he sees his friends pursuing dreams
hearing of grand adventures believing
he's destined for more wanting more to
me the twin sons have always represented
Luke's two paths his two choices will he
stay with his aunt and uncle tending to
the farm sticking with the familiar the
security of home pushing down his desire
for adventure or will he get off this
desert rock and give in to the burning
desire that he has for something else a
different life moving away from the
small town and exploring what else is
out there following up his dreams and
wishes with action that is what the twin
Sun scene has always meant to me and I
think we can all relate to that struggle
at least once in our life or maybe
throughout our entire life the unease of
your future are you making the right
decision what the hell do I want to do
with the rest of my life we can all
relate to Luke in that regard the scene
would be nothing without John Williams
score though the score ramps up it pulls
you in this short little moment is my
personal favorite in the Star Wars saga
and number five on this list Walter
Walter what are you doing you got it
wrong number four
the climax of the original Star Wars
movie was so good they did it two more
times the phenomenon that was that first
Star Wars film culminated in this moment
it featured classic lines
[Music]
thrilling action
in the last second rescue the trench
battle was one of the major recut that
George Lucas's wife at the time Marcia
had a huge part in a lot of the credit
for how this film peaked goes to her as
she completely reassembled it to the
breathtaking exhilarating sequence that
is as classic and timeless as any other
moment on this list the hundreds of
hours that went into the original
effects for this scene paid off in the
best way possible while the special
edition and changes after that have
updated those effects we shouldn't ever
forget what a visual triumph this turned
out to be at the time the first Death
Star battle continues to delight new and
old fans to this day it capped off a
groundbreaking film with unparalleled
action and held the emotion of the movie
intact people still love it and for good
reasons number three
[Music]
I love this scene it's exactly what it
should be mysterious
disturbing and that over-explained in
the film Goethe tells Luke to go into
the cave and not bring his weapons which
Luke of course doesn't listen to what
turns out to be inside is a twisted
reflection Luke encounters Vader and
defeats him only to find his own face is
behind Vader's mask this force shadows
the big reveal later but seeing it
without knowing that is still very
powerful and effective warnings are
falling to the dark side are constant
from Yoda to Luke as his impatience and
unwillingness to accept what the force
is capable of frustrates the Jedi Master
Yoda and Luke's teacher-student
relationship is a big reason the
character work and Empire is so strong
and well done it's in this scene that
Luke is forced to acknowledge the pull
of the dark side and that he may not be
as different from his enemy as he
previously thought
number two sister if you will not turn
to the dark side then perhaps this is my
favorite lightsaber fight period
it's not about spectacle it's about
emotion everything comes to a head and
the funny thing about this being my
favorite lightsaber fight is that the
lightsaber is barely used the sequence
is all about dialogue about tension
about the struggle about the internal
conflict when Luke is hiding in the
shadows as his father is on the hunt
toying with him speaking to him and when
he starts talking to Luke about his
sister Leia the tension is at its peak
and then Vader says if you will not turn
to the dark side then perhaps she will
and then Luke pops up in a moment of
pure rage his instincts have kicked in
he just wants to bash he just wants to
put an end to it all he snapped he let
his emotions get the best of him he's
playing right into the Emperor's hand
this moment is one of the most epic
moments in the entire saga Luke begins
to swing wildly it's not elegant it's
not choreographed he's seeing red
training does not matter bad
bash bash and when Vader stumbles and
becomes vulnerable he's hanging on the
rail
Luke's emotions explode he's wailing on
his father he's bashing on the very
symbol of oppression and evil in the
galaxy I absolutely love this scene it's
the perfect ending to the original
trilogy Luke snaps he comes to and
realizes he's giving them exactly what
they want he refuses to join and then
this father is redeemed it's perfect in
every way
by far my personal favorite lightsaber
fight because it's not about flips or
force pulls or gymnastics it's there to
serve the story and not just spectacle I
love it
[Music]
and the number one best starwars
original trilogy moment is No
the ultimate spoiler the ultimate twist
the ultimate moment
Luke's true parentage was a true shocker
I recall seeing it for the first time
and being in awe of what I had just
heard
how could Darth Vader the baddest bad
guy in the galaxy be our hero Luke
Skywalker's dad how obi-wan lied to him
to us why just as Luke is yelling in
anguish we felt the same way inside
confusion anger despair it all began to
toil around inside us very few lines in
movie history if any have had that
effect on the audience watching it's a
bona fide iconic moment that is not only
the best in the Star Wars saga but one
of the best most memorable and legendary
moments in the history of cinema thank
you so much for having me on the show
Walter it's been a blast and it's been
an honor if you guys the viewers like
Star Wars
check out the hello grito youtube
channel you might get a kick out of it I
want to thank hello grito once again for
coming on the show make sure you check
out his channel for some really great
insightful Star Wars videos over on my
personal channel I've been reviewing
season four of Star Wars rebels and also
have a review up of the last Jedi so
check it out for more Star Wars content
I want to hear what you guys think what
is your favorite Star Wars original
trilogy moment what do you want me to
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let me know to keep in touch like my
facebook page facebook.com slash awesome
walter b or follow along on twitter to
take part in more polls about what may
be covered in the future Merry Christmas
and Happy New Year
top five we'll be back next week to kick
off 2018 see you then
[Music]
you